I worked sure odd job so we got Google  hunting and at that point I was that was  we sold the script and I thought I was  set for life I mean you're sitting on a  winning lottery ticket  too much of a [ __ ] to cash it three  hundred thousand dollars three hundred  thousand dollars I had to split it with  Matt  come on we got 150. then agent manager  thing taxes you ended up with five  dollars and who said no seventy five  thousand dollars  so I I said she was buy a new Jeep  Cherokee  for 56 000.  which left me with twenty thousand  dollars which almost covered the  insurance for the year so I managed to  basically hit the lottery and  simultaneously go broke